you know it's it's an avenue  not just to make a lot of money or lose  a lot of money but it's also an avenue  for money laundering and it's also a  place where white supremacists  apparently are taking options i mean  it's problematic at best in so many ways  um how do you see what's happening in  the crypto space today  i i don't think the crypto space has any  more problematic issues than  the internet society at large mainstream  media wall street  um you know i think it's a new avenue of  innovation and i think every avenue of  innovation has good characters and bad  characters so how do i look at it i look  at it as a new platform where consumers  and humans will evolve  and all the good and the bad that comes  along with human behavior will play out  on the platforms